THE ASSEMBLY MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE IS
CALLED TO ORDER- WE ARE GOING
TO BE WAITING FOR A QUORUM- BUT
I WILL READ SOME OPENING
COMMENTS- TO BEGIN WITH. I
WELCOME TO THE FIRST HEARING.
OF THE MILITARY AND VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE WHETHER
YOU'RE HERE IN PERSON WATCHING
VIRTUALLY OR ON THE PHONE LINES
I'M GRATEFUL THAT YOU HAVE
JOINED HERE. US HERE ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER FLOOR. AND WE ARE. IN
THE MIDDLE OF CLOVIS SO I WOULD
LIKE TO GO OVER SOME ITEMS-
WHILE WE WERE OR WE ARE A
ACCOMMODATING ALL OUR
WITNESSES- DURING THIS ONGOING
PANDEMIC WE'RE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN THIS
HEARING AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE.
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR THIS WITNESS- TESTIMONY
TODAY FOR THOSE WHO ARE PRESENT
ON THE CHAMBER FLOOR AND IN THE
GALLERY WE ARE HAVING TO
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON.
HEARING IN THIS SPACE WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHORS.
A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FOOT SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE THAT ARE HERE
TODAY AND THE HEARING. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HANDS
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC COULD NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ONCE YOU FINISH
TESTIFIED THAT TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO TWO PEOPLE AT A TIME.
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING ONE- MAKING
USE OF OUR- WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPTAL.
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SAID MEMBERS CAN
WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM. I
CAN ALSO ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
WITNESSES THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT
DELAY FOR THE STREAM FROM THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
SO PLEASE BE PATIENT. WE WILL
ALSO B USING AN AT&T MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT
DELAY SO AGAIN I ASK ALL
INVOLVED TO PLEASE REMAIN
PATIENT. THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS ONE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
LET ME REPEAT THAT ONE. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
MILITARY AND VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE- AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV OR MONITOR SCREEN
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS I WILL
ONLY BE ACCEPTING FIVE COLORS
IN SUPPORT AND FIVE COLORS IN
OPPOSITION AND FIVE CALLERS WHO
IDENTIFIES WINNERS ON EACH BILL
IF YOU'RE CALLING AND PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO AS- THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOU ARE TESTIFYING ON.
AS AT THE BEGINNING AT THE
BEGINNING OF THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE BE SURE TO
MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN YOU ARE
NOT SPEAKING. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A LEAD
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL. YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF NTIL
YOU'RE CALLED TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE
PLEASE CALL THE COMMITTEE
OFFICE AT ONE. NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE THREE FIVE EIGHT
THREE. AND COMMITTEE STAFF WILL
DO THEIR BEST TO ASSIST YOU.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. ADDITIONALLY PLEASE
NOTE THAT THE GUIDELINES FOR
THIS BILL FOR A BILLS HEARD IN
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY ARE. TO
ALLOW TESTIMONY FROM TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK FOR MARK NO MORE THAN ONE
MINUTE EACH. THEY CALL THEIR
GROUPS AND ENTITIES THAT ARE
NEITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. WILL BE ALLOWED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY FOR NO MORE THAN
ONE MINUTE WHEN I. WHEN I CALL
FOR TRAINERS IF A MEASURE. HAS
MORE THAN TWO ENTITIES IN THE
TWEENER CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL
BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR ONE
MINUTE EACH. BECAUSE OF THE
HARD STOP TIME PUBLIC COMMENT
UNFORTUNATELY WILL BE LIMITED
TODAY TO FIVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AD FIVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WHEN YOU'RE CALLED
UPON BY THE AT&T MODERATOR YOU
WILL. ONLY BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND THE
STANCE ON THE MEASURE THAT IS
BEING DEBATED. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. AND FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO A ROLL
CALL ASK QUESTIONS OR PROVIDE A
COMMENT YOU WILL NEED TO RAISE-YOUR MICROPHONE SO STAFF COULD
ACTIVATE IT. WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEECH. AND ALSO-
DO PLEASE STAND UP AND FACE THE
MICROPHONE WHEN SPEAKING TO
ENSURE THAT YOUR VOICE IS
AUDIBLE AND CAN BE RECORDED.
FOR THE AUTHORS OF BILLS TODAY
EACH MEMBER WILL BE- EACH
MEMBER PRESENTED TODAY WILL BE
PROVIDED AN OPENING AND CLOSING
STATEMENTS HERE TO LEAVE
WITNESSES WILL BE ANNOUNCED BY
THE CHAIR. AND AND AS I HAVE
PREVIOUSLY STATED OF WILL HAVE
ONE MINUTE TO PROVIDE-
TESTIMONY. SO WE ARE GOING TO
BE WAITING FOR. A QUORUM BEFORE
WE CAN GET STARTED I APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T ADOPTED THE
KID IN THE RULES OF THIS
MAIENSCHEIN SO WE ARE LOOKING
FOR. OF TWO MORE. TWO MORE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF ONE MORE
ONE MORE. THANK YOU. TWENTY SIX
RIGHT. YOU TOO MANY STEPS YEAH.
THAT'S FINE OKAY. THREE ONE
FIVE. THIS IS AN EASY SNACK
ITEMS ON THIS MATTER. FILE OKAY
SO WE HAVE TO OFFER FURTHER
OKAY- I'M SORRY I THOUGHT IT
WAS. THE WAY.
OKAY GREAT TO
MARK THIRTY ALL OF. WE JUST
NEED OUR WAITING AGAIN.
THERE'S
A SENSE OF WHAT. SKINNER.
ALL
RIGHT WE WILL- GO AGAIN GO
AHEAD GET STARTED MR SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IRWIN VOEPEL. BOERNER HORVATH
DALY. FRAZIER MATHIS HERE
MURATSUCHI. PETRIE-NORRIS RAMOS.
SALAS SMITH. I HAVE SIX ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM A. I.
AND- BECAUSE THIS IS THE FIRST
HEARING OF THIS COMMITTEE THE
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
ADOPTION THE COMMITTEE RULES BY
THE MOTION A SECOND. THANK YOU
HAVE A- MOTIONS DOT THE
COMMITTEE RULES THAT IS- MISTER
MURATSUCHI BY US. OKAY GET
MOVEMENT MURATSUCHI SECOND
MATHIS IRWIN. HI VOEPEL.
BOERNER HORVATH DALY. FRAZIER
MATHIS. MURATSUCHI WHICH I
PETRIE-NORRIS. RAMOS SALAS
SMITH SMITH I. SIX BEFORE WE
PROCEED TO OUR FIRST AUTHOR
LET'S TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON
CONSENT- AB TWO TWENTY FIVE
GRADE TO PASS THE PREPARATIONS
AB ONE- THE TEN- TO TRY DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS H. A R. SEVEN
PATTERSON TO BE ADOPTED TO
CONSENT AB THREE TWENTY FIVE OR
ONE TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
AB FOR ELEVEN OR ONE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AB FIVE UP FOR
FIFTY NINE MATHIS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY MATHIS DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS. EIGHTY THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN- COMMITTEE ON MILITARY
AND VETERANS AFFAIRS TO PASS TO
CONSENT TO AB THIRTEEN FIFTEEN-
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND WE HAD A
MOTION AND A SECOND. I DON'T
THINK YOU'RE MY BE. A MATHIS
MOTION SECONDED BY SMITH. RIGHT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. IRWIN HI IRWIN HI
VOEPEL BOERNER HORVATH DALY
DALY I FRAZIER. FRAZIER I
MATHIS. MATHIS I MURATSUCHI
WERE TO GI PETRIE-NORRIS RAMOS
SALAS SALAS I SMITH. SMITH HI
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD- WE WILL
HEAR THE BILLS AND FILE ORDER
BEGINNING WITH AB THREE OH FIVE
FROM MISTER MAIENSCHEIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY SIR PLEASE- BEGIN
WITH YOUR OPENING STATEMENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ACCORDING TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
ABOUT ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
VETERANS RESIDING CALIFORNIA
MORE THAN IN ANY OTHER STATE
HOWEVER GAPS EXIST IN
IDENTIFYING VETERANS AND
CONNECTING THEM WITH SERVICES.
IN VARIOUS SURVEYS VETERANS
INDICATED ONE OF THE TOP
BARRIERS TO RECEIVING SERVICES
WITH THAT THAT THEY DO NOT BE
FEEL UNDERSTOOD BY THE
PROVIDERS WHO SERVE THEM THE
COBIT PANDEMIC HAS HAD A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON VETERAN
MENTAL HEALTH ROUGHLY 54% OF
FEMALE VETERANS AND 31% OF MALE
VETERANS REPORTED NEEDING
pTHE PANDEMIC VETERANS SERVICE
MEMBERS AND SPOUSES INDICATED A
GREATER NEED FOR SERVICES AND
COMMUNICATION ABOUT HOW TO
ACCESS SERVICES THAN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. THESE NEEDS ARE
ANTICIPATED TO CONTINUE THROUGH
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE AS
MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC FACTS HAVE EXACERBATED
EXISTING CONCERNS OF MEMBERS OF
THE MILITARY COMMUNITY. AB
THREE OH FIVE WOULD REQUIRE THE
SPECIFIED STATE AGENCIES TO
INCLUDE. AT THE NEXT SCHEDULED
UPDATE QUESTIONS ON ANY INTAKE
FORMER APPLICATION TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AN APPLICANT IS
AFFILIATED WITH THE UNITED
STATES ARMED FORCES. SO THEY
CAN BE NOTIFIED OF ELIGIBILITY
FOR STATE AND FEDERAL VETERANS
BENEFITS. THIS BILL AIMS TO
ENSURE SERVICE PROVIDERS IN
VARIOUS STATE AGENCIES CAN
HAVE. A PROFOUND IMPACT ON
SERVICE MEMBERS VETERANS AND
FAMILIES BY CONNECTING THEM TO
SERVICES AND CARE HERE WITH ME
THAT AT TESTIFIED SUPPORTERS
CALLIE MAE DOUGLAS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE. OKAY THE
LEAD WITNESS ON THE LINE FOR AB
THREE OH FIVE AS KELLY DOUGLAS-
MISTER DOUGLAS PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR IRWIN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KELLY MAY DOUGLAS AND
I'M NOT A BIG SOUTHWEST.
REGIONAL LIAISON FOR THE DOD
DEFENSE STATE LIAISON OFFICE.
OUR MISSION IS THAT THE STATE
AN IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF
LIFE OF MILITARY SERVICE
MEMBERS VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. RELEVANT POLICY
CHANGES. I'M HERE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE
POLICY CONTAINED WITHIN AB
THREE OH FIVE. WHICH ADDRESSES
ONE OF THAT DOT IS KEY
INITIATIVE CALLED. ASK THE
QUESTION THIS ISSUE DIRECTOR OF
A PROGRAM FIRST IMPLEMENTED IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE WITH A GOAL OF
FILLING GAPS. IN INFORMATION
AND SERVICES AVAILABLE TO THE
VETERAN COMMUNITY. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERAN AFFAIRS PROVIDES
EXCEPTIONAL SERVICES TO THE
VETERAN TO SELF IDENTIFY AND
SEEK THOSE SERVICES FOR
THEMSELVES. HOWEVER VETERANS TO
APPROACH OTHER STATE AGENCIES
MAY NOT RECEIVE THE SERVICES IF
THEY DON'T. SELF IDENTIFY OR IF
THE AGENCY SERVICE PROVIDER
ISN'T AWARE OF WHAT THE VETERAN
CAN RECEIVE. REASONS A SERVICE
MEMBER OR VETERAN MAY NOT
MENTALLY TOUGH IDENTIFIES THE
VETERAN EITHER FOR CAPE FEAR
SIX MONTHS WORKS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T AND- CONSIDER THEMSELVES
A VETERAN DUE TO SHORT SERVICE.
ASSEMBLY BECAUSE NO ONE NOW.
EVERY PROVIDERS IN VARIOUS
STATE AGENCIES CAN HAVE A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF
VETERANS I CONNECTING THEM TO
SERVICES AND CARE. THROUGH
ASKING THE SIMPLE QUESTION HAVE
YOUR FAMILY MEMBER EVER SERVED
IN THE U. S. MILITARY. TO
ADDRESS THAT AB THREE OH FIVE
WOULD REQUIRE STATE AGENCIES TO
UPDATE THEIR INTAKE FORM. FOR
STATE SERVICES WITH A QUESTION
ABOUT THE APPLICANT'S FORMER
MILITARY SERVICE. BY ASKING THE
QUESTION PROVIDERS MAKE MAY ASK
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THAT WOULD
LEAD TO IMPROVED IDENTIFICATION
OF CHALLENGES THE NEED.
ADDITIONALLY CONNECTING SERVICE
MEMBERS VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO THE APPROPRIATE
STATE VETERANS SERVICES
AGENCIES. MAY INCREASE THE ACT
THAT THE FEDERAL FUNDING AND
SUPPORT SERVICES TO PROVIDE
THAT CARE RATHERTHAN RELYING
SOLELY ON LIMITED STATE
FUNDING. CURRENTLY EIGHT STATES
HAVE INCORPORATED THIS
LANGUAGE- AND SEVENTH ST
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA HAVE
INTRODUCED BILLS WOULD POPULATE
WHICH TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND. I
STAND BY THE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS DOUG- WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC. ARE
THERE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER OR THE
GALLERY. ARE THEY ANY- WITH. IN
OFF. IN THE BCK THE- THE
CHAMBER OR GALLERY. AND NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE OR IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU TO EXPRESS
YOUR POSITION ON THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO IN A CLEAR FIVE MANAGER
IT'S FOR OR AGAINST AND THE
BILL IS AB THREE OH FIVE. WE DO
HAVE ONE LINE WE'LL GO TO LINE
FOR SIXTY FIVE OR SIX FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
KERIS LIFE WITH THE NAVY. ON
BEHALF OF THE ARMY CORPS NAVY
AND AIR FORCE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WILL TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. AND DOES
THE AUTHOR WHICH TO PROVIDE
CLOSING STATEMENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MANAGER MEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I HAVE
A- ALL RIGHT THIS BILL ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. MR
SECRETARY. FILE ITEM TO
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH FIVE BY
MAIENSCHEIN MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS MATHIS MOVE
FRAZIER SECONDS IRWIN I. PROPEL
BOERNER HORVATH DALY DALY AYE
FRAZIER FRAZIER I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I PETRIE-NORRIS
RAMOS SALAS SALAS I SMITH SMITH
I. SEVEN ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS. OUR RIGHTS OF
WE ARE READY FOR OUR NEXT-
PRESENTATION OF
REPRESENTATIONAL WILL BE A
HEARING AID J. R. TEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI WHEN YOU'RE READY
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED A TWO PERCENT- ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION TEN ON
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD THE
RECOGNIZING THE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS KOREAN IS SOLD
JUST MADE THE IN THE VIETNAM
WAR. BY URGING CONGRESS TO
GRANT THOSE OF KOREAN VETERANS
A BARRIER RIGHTS AT THE STATE
AND THE NATIONAL CEMETERIES. AS
YOU KNOW HONORABLY DISCHARGED
VETERANS SO THIS POLICY IS UP
AND THE DEPEND ON CHILDREN ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR BURIAL IN VETERANS
OF CEMETERIES IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
EXTENDED THE BURIAL BENEFITS UP
IN NATIONAL. VETERANS SYSTEM
INTEREST TO A CERTAIN MALL
REFUGEES WHO SERVED IN AMERICAN
BACKED UP GARY LAW UNITS-
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR AND THE
WHOLE SUBSEQUENTLY BECAME
NATURALIZED U. S. CITIZENS. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE UNITED
STATES THE REPUBLIC OF KOREA
AND KOREA FOR PROVIDED THE
MAJOR MILITARY SUPPORT WI FI
APPROXIMATELY. THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND REPUBLIC OF
KOREA SOLDIERS SERVING IN
VIETNAM BETWEEN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE AND A NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE. REPUBLICAN KOREA FORCES
SO FOR THE. TEN THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO INJURIES AND
THE FIVE THOUSAND NINETY NINE
KILLED IN ACTION DURING THE WAR.
IT'S MOSTLY THE SAME RATE A
POOR CAPITA ELISSA THE UNITED
STATES FORCES HOWEVER DESPITE
FIGHTING ALONGSIDE THE U. S.
ARMED FORCES DURING THE VIETNAM
WAR REPUBLIC OF KOREA VIETNAM
VETERANS SO WOULD NOT
CONSIDERED ELIGIBLE FOR BURIAL
IN ANY STATE OR NATIONAL THAT
THE ONES THE CEMETERY. I HAVE A
WITH ME A VERY MINOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS CLARIFYING THAT THE
REPUBLIC OF KOREA WAS INDEED.
THE SECOND LARGEST MILITARY
ALLY TO THE UNITED STATES- IN
THE VIETNAM WAR. SECOND ONLY TO
THE REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM ITSELF
I LOOK FORWARD TO SUBMITTING
THIS AMENDMENT- TO MAKE THE
CLARIFICATION I RESPECTIVELY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. NOW FOR
H. A R. TEN TO HONOR OUR BRAVE
KOREAN SOLDIERS WHO FOUGHT
ALONGSIDE THE U. S. SOLDIERS
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PUBBLICATO
COMMENTS ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
BACK THE CHAMBER FLOOR OR IN
THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE- CAN
WE MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES FOR-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. YOU TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON H. A R. TEN THIS
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. HE IN TURN
ALIGNED IN Q. ALL RIGHT THE
COMMITTEE ANY- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. DOES THE AUTHOR WHICH
TO PROVIDE A CLOSING STATEMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR ARRIVAL
ALL RIGHT THAN YOU DOCTOR CHOI
AND THANK YOU FOR COMMITTING TO
FIX THE ISSUE IDENTIFIED BY THE
CITY STAFF BEFORE THE FLOOR
VOTE IS MINOR ENOUGH THAT I
HAVE NO HESITATION AT ALL IN A
RECOMMENDING THAT THIS
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED. BY THE
MOTION. IN A SECOND OUR RIGHTS-
CAN I PLEASE HAVE THE SECRETARY.
READ THE ROLE FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE HR TEN BY CHOI MOVED BY
SMITH SECOND SALAS IRWIN HI-
WHEN I VOEPEL. BOERNER HORVATH
DALY DALY AYE FRAZIER FRAZIER
HI MATHIS MATHIS AYE MURATSUCHI
WE'RE TO GI PETRIE-NORRIS RAMOS.
SALAS SALAS I SMITH SMITH HI.
SEVEN ZERO ALL RIGHT AND I JUST
WANT TO CONFIRM THAT THE MOTION
BEFORE US WAS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED AND- THAT
BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU AND WE WILL MOVE ON
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CHAO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CHAU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO. WHAT
AUTHORIZED CALIFORNIA'S
MILITARY DEPARTMENT TO PERFORM
INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS OR I. S. EIGHTH AT
THE REQUEST OF. AND IN
CONSULTATION WITH OUR STATE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES-
ELEAZAR THANK YOU. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT PROTECTING THE
CYBERSECURITY OF THE STATE'S
SCHOOLS CYBERSECURITY THREATS
ARE A COMMON REALITY TODAY. AND
HAVE BECOME AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION FOR ALL
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES.
ESPECIALLY AMID A PANDEMIC THAT
HAS SHIFTED MANY PERSONAL IN
PERSON OPERATIONS ONLINE. SUCH
AS L. E. ASE. IN FACT MANY
SCHOOLS ARE. FORCED TO SHIFT
FROM IN CLASS LEARNING TO
REMOTE LEARNING. WHEN THE
PANDEMIC DANCE SCHOOLS WILL
RETURN TO REGULAR IN CLASS
LEARNING. YET SCHOOLS HAVE
INVESTED IN REMOTE TECHNOLOGY
TO IMPROVE THEIR STUDENTS
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES AND
WILL LIKELY CONTINUE TO DO SO.
THESE INVESTMENTS WHICH INCLUDE
CONNECTED TECHNOLOGY LIKE
TABLETS ARE CRITICAL TO
IMPROVING THE LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FOR STUDENTS.
NEVERTHELESS THIS TECHNOLOGY
CAN COME WITH CYBER SECURITY
RISKS. AB THIRTEEN FIFTY TO
ADDRESS THE CYBER CONCERNS BY
ALLOWING THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT TO PERFORM SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS AT THE REQUEST OF
ELEAZAR. YES SUSSMAN'S WILL BE
CONFIDENTIAL AND PAID FOR BY
THE REQUESTING LEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL.
AND HERE TO TESTIFY BY FULL IS
ANDREA BENNETT FROM CALIFORNIA
I T. IN EDUCATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AS BENNETT PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANDREA
BENNETT AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA I
EIGHTEEN EDUCATION AND NOT FOR
PROFIT PROFESSIONAL MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATIONS SUPPORTING THE IT
PROFESSIONALS WORKING IN
SCHOOL. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO
FOR OFFERING A SIMPLE BUT
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THEY GIVE A TECHNOLOGY OUR
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN. CONTINUALLY
EXPANDING FOR YEARS
UNFORTUNATELY WITH THIS
INCREASE IN TECHNOLOGY IT SAVES
HAVE COME A SIMILAR INCREASE IN
CYBER SECURITY THREATS.
ALTHOUGH HAS ONLY BECOME
EXACERBATED BY THE COLD
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AT SCHOOLS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA RAPIDLY
DEPLOYED DISTANCE LEARNING
MODELS FOR STUDENTS THAT WERE
CALLED UPON OUR ABILITY TO ALSO
INCREASE. THE FIRST STEP TO
HELP MITIGATE THE THREATS OF
IDENTIFYING VULNERABILITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY HAVING A PRIVATE
OR THIRD PARTY ENTITY
PERFORMANCE CYBER SECURITY
AUDIT CAN BE EXTREMELY COSTLY.
MANY L. EIGHT SIMPLY DO NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO EITHER
ACCURATELY AFFECT THEIR OWN
NETWORK OR CONTRACT WITH AN
AGENCY TO DO SO. THIS BILL
TAKES AIM AT SOLVING THIS ISSUE.
AUTHORIZED THE MILLER
DEPARTMENT AT REQUEST OF AN
ALLEY A TO PERFORM AN
INDEPENDENT SECURITY AUDIT OF
THE ALLEY A- IT ALSO ENSURES
THAT HE ALLEY I CAN WORK WITH
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT ON THE
PROVISIONS OF THE AUDIT. AND
MAKES CLEAR THE FINDINGS OF THE
AUDIT BUT THE FINDINGS OF THE
AUDIT ARE DISCLOSED ONLY TO
RETALIATE. OUR OLD. MANAGE
HIGHLY SENSITIVE DATA FROM
CERTAIN SECURITY NUMBERS TO
MEDICAL RECORDS. AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY TWO REPRESENTS A SMALL
BUT IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
HELPING SCHOOLS. SECURE AND
PROTECTED STATUS I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAS
BENEFITS- MODERATOR THERE ARE
NO LISTED LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO- WE WILL NOW TAKE
A PUBLIC COMMENTS ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER FLOOR OR IN THE GALLERY.
HI HERE OF NOT SO WE'LL MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINE MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE OR
IN THE QUEUE. YOU TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON áP THIRTEEN FIFTY
TWO THIS PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE
NO LINES IN Q. I THANK TO THIS
MODERATOR- FOR THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS TO THE AUTHOR WISH TO
PROVIDE A CLOSING STATEMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. VERY GOOD. MR A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO I DO LIKE
THIS VOTE I VOTED FOR- THIS
BILL I VOTED FOR IT IN PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE ON MY LEGISLATIVE
RECORD AS LONG REFLECT MY VIEW
THAT PUBLIC AGENCIES
CYBERSECURITY VULNERABILITIES
ARE. A SERIOUS ISSUE NOT ONLY
OF LOCAL AND STATE BUT NATIONAL
SECURITY AND THAT THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT IS THE RIGHT AGENCY
TO TAKE THEM ON IT IT'LL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW- IS C.
ND TAKES ON THESE NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES BOTH IN TERMS
OF COST AND PRIORITIZATION OF.
TAXING TAT- PASCHING AND THIS
BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- MISTER
SECRETARY CAN I PLEASE HAVE THE
ROLE. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY
TWO BY CHAO MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS MOVE BY
FRAZIER MATHIS SECOND. IRWIN HI
IRWIN HI VOEPEL.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I DALY DALY HI FRAZIER FRAZIER
HI MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
MURATSUCHI MERCER GI
PETRIE-NORRIS RAMOS ALMOST HI
SALAS SALAS I SMITH. SALAS
SMITH HI. NINE ZERO ALL RIGHT
THAT BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU AGAIN
COLLEAGUES. OKAY OUR NEXT AND
LAST AUTHOR IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS AND THAT WILL BE FOR AB
ONE OH SEVEN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS- FOR THAT MOTION SECOND
AND THIRD I WILL BE BRIEF-
MEMBERS SAY PERCENT ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE OF SEVEN WHICH WILL
EXPAND WHICH EXPANDS AND
IMPROVES THE TEMPORARY
LICENSURE PROGRAM FOR SPOUSES
OF ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS
IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW MILITARY
SPOUSES OR FOR MORE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO BE. UNEMPLOYED OR
UNDEREMPLOYED AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY TO THE TUNE OF THE SIX
TIMES AS AS MUCH WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE I DO HAVE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE. ALL RIGHTS AND- WE
HAVE MISS DOUGLAS ON THE LINE
ARE READY SO- PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME AGAIN THAT'S
KELLY MAY DOESN'T SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF ARMS DEFENSE. I'M
HERE TO SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE POLICY CHANGES PROPOSED
WITHIN AB ONE OH SEVEN
ADMITTED. OBJECTING LICENSURE
RECIPROCITY AND PORTABILITY
ISSUE FOR THE THOUSANDS OF OUR
MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN A PRIORITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
THE WHITE HOUSE CURRENTLY IS
ALSO PRIORITIZING EASIEST THESE
ISSUES WITH THE FIRST LADY WE
AND STATING THAT JOINING FORCES
INITIATIVE. FIRST EMPLOYMENT
AND UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION. TECHNIQUES TO
EXPAND EMPLOYMENT AND CAREER
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MILITARY SPOUSES. AMONG OTHER
QUALITY OF LIFE AND THEY SAID
IT. I THE TWENTY TWO ONE THAT
DEFENSE AUTHORIZATION ACT
SECTION TWO EIGHT THREE- DIRECT
THE MILITARY SERVICES TO
INCORPORATE SPECIFIC QUALITY OF
LIFE MEASUREMENTS TO INCLUDE.
THE EXTENT OF STATE SUPPORT FOR
MILITARY SPOUSE EMPLOYMENT AND
LYFT ENTER INTO THEIR FUTURE
THE THING DECISION. OKAY
DOCTORS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY STATE SPECIFIC
LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS THAT CAN
CAUSE DELAYS AND GAPS IN
EMPLOYMENT. WITH AN ANNUAL
CROSS THE RELOCATION RATE TEN
TIMES HIGHER THAN THEIR
CIVILIAN COUNTERPARTS. BECAUSE
MILITARY FINANCE ARE RELATIVELY
SHORT. AND 34% OF MILITARY
SPOUSES IN THE WORK FORCE ARE
IN LIKE THE PROFESSION- IN
ADDITION MILITARY SPOUSE
EMPLOYMENT UNEMPLOYMENT WITH
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN THE
BILLION MARK. FOR PRIOR TO THE
PROJECT AND THEN AGAIN THIS
TREND IS ONLY EXPECTED TO
EXPAND AS A RESULT OF THE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES. BROUGHT ON
BY A LOT OF IT MAKING. SURE THE
MILITARY SERVICE- THE MILITARY
SERVICES IN THE STATE. THE
INDIVIDUAL AT ISSUES FROM
FAMILIES THAT I DESCRIBED LET
REPRESENTS A KEY THAT THAT
TRANSLATE INTO A BROADER
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION ISSUE
THAT CAN UNDERMINE PERSONNEL
NUMBERS. AND THEREFORE OUR
NATION'S SECURITY THIS IS
BECAUSE SERVICE MEMBERS
FREQUENTLY BY ECONOMIC ISSUES-
AND CONCERNED AT THE TOP REASON
WHY THEY DISCONTINUE MILITARY
SERVICE. MILITARY FAMILIES LIKE
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE OFTEN
REQUIRED TO INCOMES TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. IF AS A RESULT OF
THE STRUCTURAL ECONOMIC
TERRIERS STATE THROUGH NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN MILITARY STUFF
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO SECURE
EMPLOYMENT IN CALIFORNIA. THE
DURATION OF THEIR STOCK WITH
THE CITY IN THE STATE SERVICE
MEMBERS COULD BE PUT INTO A
DIFFICULT POSITION OF CHOOSING
BETWEEN SERVING THEIR COUNTRY.
FOR THE ECONOMIC NEEDS OF THEIR
FAMILY THE DEPARTMENT
APPRECIATE THE COMMONSENSE
APPROACH THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS HAS TAKEN IN AB ONE OH
SEVEN BUILDING OFF THE PREVIOUS
EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN SUPPORT THE
MILITARY COMMUNITY. WE BELIEVE
THAT STANDING A PROVISION THAT
HAS EXISTED FOR THE LAST SIX
YEARS THE COVER ALL RELEVANT
LICENSE LIKE MEETING BOARD. IS
A WIN WIN FOR MILITARY SPOUSES
BOARD THE STATE AND THE PUBLIC
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
STAND BY THE ANSWERING
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR- TESTIMONY AND THERE ARE
NO OTHER LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN THE BACK THE
CHAMBER FLOOR OR THE GALLERY. I
DON'T SEE ANY SO MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE OR
IN THE QUEUE. STATE YOUR
POSITION ON THIS. PLEASE PRESS
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD FOR AB. ONE OH SEVEN.
WHAT A LINE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE FOUR SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
STILL CARE SLAPPED WITH THE
NAVY ON BEHALF OF THE ARMY
MARINE CORPS NAVY AND AIR FORCE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
ECONOMIC QUALITY OF LIFE AND
MILITARY READINESS COMMONSENSE
MEASURE THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE. FOR SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN
ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON SYLVIA SO
LEAST SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE
COUNTY OF YUBA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE.
FOR FIFTY NINE FOUR FIVE NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SANDY PERSON
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENSE COMMUNITIES ALLIANCE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO FOR THE LINES IN Q.
OUR RIGHTS OF VERY GOOD WILL
MOVE TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE MISTER SALAS YOU
HAVE A CLOSING STATEMENT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH MY STAFF AND- I
TRUST THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION-
DISPELLED DEFINITELY HAS A- AND
I RECOMMENDATION FOR ME DO I
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND. OUR
RIGHTS. AND MR SECRETARY
COMPLETED THE ROLE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB ONE OH SEVEN
SALAS MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MOVED BY MATHIS
SECOND BUT BOERNER HORVATH.
IRWIN HI- WHEN I VOEPEL. VOEPEL
HI BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I DALY. DALY
AYE FRAZIER FRAZIER HI MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MURATSUCHI WE'RE TO
GI PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
I RAMOS RAMOS I SALAS SALAS I
SMITH. SMITH I LIVE IN ZERO ALL
RIGHT CONGRATULATIONS AND THAT
BILL IS OUT AND THAT IS ALL THE
BILLS- IN THIS HEARING AND I'M
AND I HAVE MR SECRETARY- PLEASE
GO THROUGH THE BILL'S ONCE MORE
SO- ALL THE MEMBERS CAN
COMPLETE. VOTING AND WE WILL-
WE'LL SEE THE- LEAVE. WE'LL GO
THROUGH THIS ONE MORE TIME AND
THEN. WILL BE ADOPTED. VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I PETRIE-NORRIS
THREE NORTH AYE RAMOS RAMOS AYE
SALAS. SALAS I. ONE ZERO. FOR
ADD ONS CONSENT. AB TWO DOES
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. TWO TWENTY
FIVE GREAT TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM THREE
AB ONE ZERO ZERO TWO CHOI DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS FILE
ITEM SIX A. G. R. SEVEN
PATTERSON BE ADOPTED. TO
CONSENT FILE ITEM AB THREE
TWENTY FIVE IRWIN DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BOTTOM NINE A.
B. FOUR ONE ONE IRWIN TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM TEN
A. B. FOUR FIVE FOUR FIVE NINE
MATHIS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM ELEVEN
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY MATHIS DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS FILE
ITEM TWELVE A. B. THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN COMMITTEE ON MILITARY
AND VETERANS AFFAIRS TO PASS TO
CONSENT. FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN COMMITTEE ON
MILITARY AND VETERANS AFFAIRS
DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
VOEPEL. PROPEL I.
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI
PETRIE-NORRIS NORTH AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS HIGH WINDS- FILE ITEM TWO
FOR ADD ONS AB THREE OH FIVE BY
MAIENSCHEIN DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS VOEPEL. VOEPEL I
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI
PETRIE-NORRIS NORTH AYE RAMOS
RAMOS I LIVE IN. ZERO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. J. R. TEN BY
CHOI. MOTIONS BE ADOPTED.
VOEPEL THE BILL I ON HER UP
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI
PETRIE-NORRIS NORTH AYE RAMOS
MOST BY. ELEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
FIVE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO CHAO
DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I- THREE NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I.
WE RESERVE THE
LAST MONTH YEAH EVERYBODY ABOUT
IT I'M NOT ALL RIGHT WELL- I
WOULD WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC FOR THIS VERY- FAST-
COMMITTEE HEARING- WE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY STAYS
INVOLVED WITH THE PROCESS IT'S
VITAL- TO THE LEGITIMACY OF
DEMOCRACY AND- THIS HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY MILITARY VETERANS
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.